[Music]
chess
is an ancient game but over the past few
months
it's got huge again now you might think
that traditional esports are the only
games with
height moments or hilarious mistakes but
chess on twitch
is an absolute gold mine and here are
the best of the best this is the top 10
chess moments
[Music]
when xuc joined the pogchamps tournament
nobody expected him to be
some sort of chess god they did however
expect him to last longer than six moves
versus moist critical
at first it was only critical who
realized xqc had fallen for the trap
i can't believe it i can't believe it
he just lost but it didn't take too long
for xqc to realize what was going on
right away so i'm not sure that i like
the like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
you know when i said it'd be fun to see
a check made in four earlier i was i was
joking it was
i it wasn't real there was joy on one
side
disappointment on the other but for the
casters there was only
disbelief all right so we're gonna be
watching this chess match here guys
um it's between moist critical
and xqc
well i guess that's the end of the chess
match between moist critical and xqc
another riveting bout between those two
magnus carlsen is the world champion in
chess
he has been since 2013. the norwegian
campus he's going crazy and we have a
so you might expect him to be used to
big chess tournaments by now
even when they're online but well you'd
be surprised
that's hard to imagine though because
you've been playing five days like this
oh no way that's right at the rapid
blitz 2021 tournament
magnus showed up to his match against
hikaru
shirtless i wonder if that offers any
kind of
tactical advantage
at number eight we have resident sleeper
this
i i'm gonna i'm gonna venture a guess
that this young man is gonna hear from
his manager
about this afterwards now after that
last entry
you might be thinking that showing up
shirtless is the worst thing you can do
during a big chess game that's being
streamed to
tens of thousands of people well not
if this guy has anything to say about it
or the chess moves on the board
do you recognize the player because i
can't tell from
so we have we have pro chess league
history here
this i i'm gonna i'm gonna venture a
guess that this young man is gonna hear
from his manager
about this afterwards
coming in at number seven we have eric
hanson
a grandmaster who's not usually lost for
words
except for this one time in a tense
match with another grandmaster
and with time on his side hanson could
practically
taste the win his opponent was
desperately playing for a draw but
surely hanson had it covered oh
buddy oh buddy
you drew what's up
we're checking back in with xqc now for
our number six
entry with this big blunder oh no
no no no okay
let me set the stage for this one he's
up against foosley
he has his queen protecting his king and
fusely has
no pieces except for her king the
commentators are discussing the simplest
way for xqc to close out this
clear victory but things are never
simple when it comes to xqc
the simplest way to do this and he's
doing a great job
is you want to keep your queen a night's
distance away from the enemy king
except when it's all the way in the
corner as i said if you have your queen
a nice square away
then it's stalemate because your queen
will take away the remaining squares
i like that it's a very stressful way to
go king of five don't
next up at number five we have the
mountain and the moog hill
squeeze the biceps make them explode
if you haven't watched game of thrones
then you might not know half thor
bjornsson better known as the mountain
he's a professional strong man that
turned to
gm hans niemann for some chess advice
should i move the queen i want to move
the queen from
d that's good yeah that's great that's
great
then you're then you're attacking that's
great
you can bring your queen into the attack
yeah perfect during a game though it was
the mountain who was dishing out the
advice
could chess weightlifting be the next
big thing
i'm going to get into some curls while
you're playing just the practice
you do some positive cross champ squeeze
the biceps
make them explode
moving on to number four we have xqc's
beautiful
fork now i had a fork belt oh my god
it's so
beautiful a fork in chest is where your
opponent has to choose which of their
two pieces they want to save
sqc pulled one of these off but things
went
comically bad from there
oh my god and if he takes a take
he doesn't see it right off okay
last match
next up at number three we have hikaru's
pre-moving
i can also trade and take and take and
it takes i take
it takes takes takes 22 queen h4 g3
knight g3 check c6 queen b7 knight h1
king there
i don't know what's going on i'm just
going to castle i don't want to think
too much so pre-moving
is the art of planning ahead before you
make your move
something that only the absolute best
players in the world can master
will you ever be able to reach the same
level of pre-moving as hikaru though
you tell me rook g1 uh rook takes h2
check queen h4 chuck queen
chuck me pretty move at all
and while that is insanely impressive
it's also
very easy to meme on i can also do sorry
i i can also do nicaragua yeah
it's like it should be 394 be seven
rupees seven rupees by seven land
publishing afraid and probably c four
and
okay like a bishop could be like another
five [ __ ] should be six and then oh
he's got bishop
i've got two five six six eight ninety
seven ninety-five
moving on to number two now we have
hands
getting put on blast slow down
[Music]
hans neiman is one of the best grand
masters on the planet
sometimes he likes to stream other
people's games
xqc being one of them knight f3
check main one men knight f3 come on
buddy
come on come on i know you see it as the
game ramped up hans got
pretty excited which would normally be
fine
but it was 5 a.m and it turns out
the hands doesn't live alone night of
three
check main one man knight f3 come on
buddy
come on come on i know you see it i know
you see it no
go slow down slow down
[Music]
sorry my bad sorry
[Music]
yo my sorry i thought i was
and finally at number one we have the
magnus
troll we've talked about magnus already
in this video as the current world
champion
most people would fear playing him but
what if they
didn't know they were playing him that's
what happened to yann gustafsson
a chess grandmaster who streamed the
game against the norwegian
by the name of salomon what we got oh
our friend johan salomon who already
crushed me yesterday
is back aren't you playing for the
norwegian national team mr salomon what
are you doing here
go to sleep prepare for your next
opponent yan
thought he was playing a random
high-ranked norwegian player but he was
actually facing off against magnus
carlsen
yan didn't know that but he knew
something was up
so why is this guy blitzing out every
move it's very confusing to me he never
thinks like these moves aren't obvious
the penny never quite dropped for yan
and he lost the game wondering
how exactly this random user played like
a literal world champ
good game good game but yeah some crazy
moves there
played instantly
yeah i don't know that was a very
strange game
good game mr salomon very confusing game
really
[Music]
all right then which one of those was
your favorite
have you picked up chess since it
exploded onto the twitch scene
i'm a little bit rusty but i'm thinking
of getting back into it thanks for
watching guys
make sure you subscribe on your way out
the door and i'll see you all
in the next one
does that happen
what the [ __ ] happened this is so
bad what a bad this is so miss started